well it's a big week for shipping
holiday packages if you have some you
might want to listen up if you have
gifts that you want to to arrive on time
and you don't want to pay an arm and a
lake for express shipping then you
probably need to get to the post office
today bianca holman is live to tell you
everything you need to know about all
those shipping deadlines and oh my gosh
bianca you're making me really nervous
this morning because i've got stuff at
home waiting to send
sherry well i got the little carrier
i need you to drop things off at my desk
i'll bring them here to the post office
for you okay
yes
i'll be our own mail carrier but these
folks here at the post office this
distribution center they are working
hard these are the hardest working folks
of the holiday i'm joined by gene barton
the customer relations with usps
so tell us you all have to hire a lot
more people this season we did we hired
about 40 000 employees nationwide so
we've got plenty of firepower and we are
capable of taking care of our customers
this holiday season i mean that's a
concern for a lot of people they're
worried about the supply chain issues
these deliveries getting there on time
but you all have put things in place to
make sure that happens absolutely we've
hired
as i said some extra employees and we've
also rented
a lot more vehicles to assist with the
delivery this season good good to hear
also some things that people may not
know you can actually print your
shipping label this is some tips for you
all listing at home before you get to
the post office tell us more about that
absolutely so our customers can head on
over to usps.com
look for click and ship and from there
they can pay for the label print the
label have a carrier pick it up at the
house so they won't even have to come to
the post office all right so let's get
this uh the picture up of the dates the
deadlines one of them being today for
ground shipping for usps so also tell us
about those other dates december 17th is
our deadline for first class mail
december 18th is the deadline for
priority mail and december 23rd is our
deadline for priority mail express all
right all great information so if you
don't want to pay a premium get to the
post office today if you haven't gotten
your gifts yet just get a gift card they
got cards at the post office just just
make it easy for yourself back to you
guys in the studio
excellent advice now speaking